grey's anatomy season 2 episode 16 and
17 i heard were the bomb so i'm gonna
check it out
[Music]
oh
okay immediately a lot of blood
screaming person paramedics emts need to
speak up here
um
can't tell what's happening here it
looks like her arm is inside his chest
is she holding together a broken artery
a broken blood vessel that is bleeding
out paramedics found him unconscious and
bleeding mechanisms of injury are
unknown but he has a large sucking chest
wound vitals tachycardic in the 140s bp
holding in the 90s with that massive
blood loss i expect the tachycardia to
be worse because what happens is when
you lose blood your body actually loses
blood pressure because there's not
enough liquid inside your blood vessels
when your body drops blood pressure
there isn't enough blood reaching vital
areas your brain your kidneys your liver
so what your body does to compensate for
that is it tries to pump faster that's
why the tachycardia happens causes
respiratory effort absent breath sounds
on the right side absent breath sounds
on the right sounds like that there's a
collapsed lung on that side which can
happen with a penetrating injury chest
wall injury bubbling at the side of the
wound he's shocking and getting a little
cyanotic shocky means that his blood
pressure is getting quite low which
means he's not able to perfuse his
organs cyanotic means that he's not
perfusing his skin well meaning that he
starts actually turning blue because
there's not enough oxygen reaching his
skin cells from the small little
capillaries the small little blood
vessels that uh feed the skin its
oxygenation why do you have your hand
inside my patient i tried to tamper out
the wound with gauze and pressure but
the only thing that would stop the
bleeding was my hand every time i try to
move it he starts bleeding out putting
pressure on a wound is the most
important thing you can do other than
creating a makeshift tourniquet on the
scene because putting pressure can
actually stop blood flow to that area if
you stop blood flow you can decrease
blood loss there's a chance that some
blood vessels specifically arteries that
are muscular walls can actually spasm so
hard that they cut off circulation
decreasing blood loss can i take my hand
out now you don't stick your hand inside
of a patient when you don't know how he
was injured yeah i know that now out of
my room she gets to stay she has her
hands stuck inside my patient yeah so
there should be an or being prepped
right away if you have an emt telling
you that if i let go bleeding is
instantly going to happen that means you
need to open up the patient and prepare
them for surgery because that means
there's serious damage to one of the
important blood vessels in the chest you
have your finger on a major bleeder mr
carlson is running out of time
the only thing that you have won is an
all-expense paid trip to the o.r
what do you want me to do i want you to
make that woman stop screaming and tell
us what happened and also make sure that
everyone wears face shields because what
he called a major bleeder will squirt in
everyone's eyes this is carlson
are you injured
can you hear me
if you were in the medical field please
don't ever do that support be a human
first do not yell back at someone who's
obviously in a state of shock is this
okay
me being in here like this once dr burke
scrubs in he'll have you remove your
hand and then you can go this is
obviously not okay because when she put
her hand in it wasn't sterile the
patient's gonna need major iv
antibiotics after the fact but in this
case it's acceptable why because had she
not done that the patient would have
bled out and died the trade-off here of
potentially getting infection but to
save his life acutely is warranted
that's why whenever people make
overwhelming or over-generalized
statements about medicine i have to
point out that it's right sometimes
wrong sometimes it depends on the
situation and on the patient it's why
it's so hard when you guys ask me very
specific questions about your own health
for me to answer them no she's fine
acute anxiety reaction number two diets
are pampered to calm her down is she in
shock i'll say can you tell us exactly
what happened maybe try a different
approach dude how about just asking are
you okay what happened is my husband and
his war on best can you stop calling me
a [ __ ] [ __ ] best friend separate them
decided to build some kind of big gun
they get an exact replica of the finest
allied anti-tank weapon of world war ii
and they try to shoot the thing i'm the
gunner james is the loader okay we
follow the specifications exactly you
should see it it's a 60 millimeter one
and a half pound rocket where's grey's
anatomy's hospital seattle right
yeah missiles aren't legal in seattle i
don't need to look that one up he shot
himself with the bazooka like i said
morons the pair of them was there an
explosion huh was there an explosion no
why
oh crap how do these guys make a real
missile in their backyard or garage
hannah
yes dr burke
what do you feel inside of mr carlson
preface that with please do not move or
remove your hand before asking what you
feel because the natural instinct of a
human when someone asks what do you feel
is to do this do not do that near a
bleeding artery or a bomb fact you
learned on this channel is your hand
touching anything hard um
i don't know
don't move your hand
a little late bud hannah i don't want
you to move okay
you should know you're starting to scare
me i would have been a little bit
manipulative in this case explain that
we're very concerned about the blood
vessel and i would put the pressure like
that because by worrying about her own
life she could faint lose control of the
hand and then boom literally bull go and
tell the charge nurse that we have a
code black and then tell him to call the
box award every hospital has their own
code structure like on the back of my
badge you could see if it flips over
there's like the emergency codes and
what each one means and i'm pretty sure
each hospital has their own designation
there's no universal one although code
blue is usually the one for someone's
heart snapping so i'm touching live
unexploded ammunition
i'm afraid so
but he's not hooked up to the machine
anymore i had dr milton take him off the
ventilator the flow of oxygen posed a
danger do they have to immediately
evacuate the entire hospital because
like there's oxygen tanks everywhere
which if there's an explosion is a very
big problem oxygen itself is not
necessarily flammable it's an accelerant
for flames
the more you know they want us to
evacuate evacuate they say why uh no but
your pager said cold black
i'm sure they said that
yes
it could be a drill
even if it's not a drill i can't
evacuate i've got an open brain on the
table
if anybody wants to go they should go
anybody want to evacuate
going once how about tell people what
they're evacuating for like he didn't
even give the full story and he's like
do you want to leave tell us why what
page did you get what's happening give
us more info dr shepard there's an
explosive device in the or next door i
need you to evacuate now yeah and i've
got a guy whose brain is exposed on this
table i'm not gonna walk away and leave
him to die i mean you could reposition
him to a safer area at least not next
door to where the bomb is
pink mist excuse me
that's what the bomb squad calls you
when you blow up bomb goes off and
anyone in range explodes into a billion
pieces this anesthesiologist has not
taken a psych course in quite some time
he has a very anxious individual that's
keeping her hand on a bomb and instead
of saying warm reassuring statements in
order to encourage her and keep her hand
on the bomb he's scaring the life out of
her trying to get her to vasovagal and
pass out on the floor take this
red
now i want you to squeeze it in even
beats
not too fast is he gonna leave
whoa
dr milton
i've got kids
oh that's savage
that's it
oh my god where's the anesthesiologist
he
um down
he left
i think i'm gonna take my hand out now
no that device is homemade which means
it's unstable and very unreliable could
be a dead but we have no way of knowing
add to that the fact that you've got a
surge in the arm next door refusing to
leave in a nervous paramedic's hand
inside the body cavity why is this guy
running down a list of everything that's
wrong with the situation and not
addressing any of it imagine you went
into a doctor's office and doctor just
rattled off every problem you have with
no plan of what to do next not a very
useful doctor's visit i am 22 years old
i should not even be in here this is
some kind of mistake
we need to clear the room they need to
defuse that situation
just a little while longer
[Music]
[Music]
did she switch hands with her
[Music]
exactly where you are this is the most
useless bomb squad person ever i swear
if i was there with zero bomb experience
i could have handled this situation
better than this dude the only thing
he's good at is dressing up as team bomb
squad like he's got the boots he's got
the whole combat look but no knowledge
no recommendations nothing time for you
to go
no i'm sorry there's nothing more you
can do here we got to cover
christina this is not another cool
surgery this ammo can go off at any time
and kill everyone in this room do you
get that if you do not have a role in
this situation you should not be in this
situation that is how i would say it and
i would say quite firmly and if the
person didn't listen i would ask the
cool bomb squad man for his handcuffs
and address the situation myself so you
have a plan right
you have a way to get me out of this
right i think this bomb squad guy has
never seen nor learned about any bomb i
think he got a halloween costume showed
up and was like damn wish i studied
bombs
emotional damage in the oil we put our
patients on the general anesthesia
yeah that involves a steady flow of pure
oxygen
yeah well can't you turn off the oxygen
in my o.r
i can and i have
but
this is your o.r
this is the or floor's main oxygen line
we have to move
okay i can't wiggle my fingers because
we can't shift the ammo and now you want
to roll out the entire gurney well
that's our safest
safest option what is the concern
they've evacuated the whole hospital you
have a person who's gonna die whether
there's oxygen below you or not what
does it concern the damaging of the
equipment i mean there's bigger worries
than that first of all the person is no
way gonna make it medically only in a
fictional medical drama could this
happen i'm surprised that paramedics
didn't start chest compressions and
explode the bomb on route to the
hospital i feel like the correct move
here is i think ethically you have to
open up the patient's chest he will
start bleeding you have to get complete
visual of the bomb and only then when
you're comfortable potentially remove it
which means likely that the patient will
die but it decreases the likelihood that
the bomb will go off killing everyone
else in the room but i think only a
bioethicist could answer this question
correctly if this was on my boards i
would probably fail if this was an sat
medical question i would not answer it
because the wrong answer loses you
points i'm going to extend the wound
when i cut bleeding it's going to
intense a lot if we're going to save mr
carlson you have to pull the ammo out
immediately patients no longer attack a
cardiac up there 95 pulse doesn't make a
whole lot of sense with all that blood
loss how is the girl with the bomb it's
meredith
the girl with the bomb is meredith
that's wifey
maybe instead of talking about your love
interest you focus on the patient who
you're operating on their brain
at least they're doing chest
compressions
maybe lower the patient you can't get
adequate pressure during chest
compressions when you're on the same
height as the patient
oh he tried the cardiac thump
oh obviously it's a medical drama
miracle
[Music]
now what
is my man just gonna hold it and rock it
to sleep i feel like he didn't even
think this through he's like what do i
do with it now it would have been great
if he's like hey siri
where is he going don't bring it outside
to where there's other people
and she's chasing it
no
i expected this to have a happy ending
is my husband um alive
yes that's got to be the most fictional
outcome ever my man was bleeding out for
five hours straight with two hands
inside of his body and he's just fine
even if he is alive in this moment he's
in the most critical state ever i see
you care where is she
she's right here yeah she just decided
to chase the bomb
oh
that's his ex-wife right my current wife
oh girl
but he's got he caught the feels
she should be evaluated not just
showered like we should give her a full
neuro exam they're like oh let's make
sure she's clean for the next episode
that was at the same time expected and
unexpected pretty impressive did you
hear about the eyeball licking craze
from japan click here to learn the truth
about that story and as always stay
happy
[Music]